les commerces ont rouvert ce week-end
ici au centre commercial one nation
paris le parking était plein dès 10h
commerçants et clients étaient ravis de
pouvoir retrouver les boutiques les
responsables ont préparé le terrain en
amont pour mettre en place le protocole
chaque magasin a clairement indiqué sa
capacité d'accueil
ce qui permet aux clients de comprendre
si toutefois on est amené à attendre les
consignes sont à l'extérieur et donc
tous les clients peuvent largement dès
l'entrée met le gel à voir les consignes
sanitaires et le nombre de personnes
maximum dans la boutique les clients
sont arrivés par vagues pour profiter de
ce premier week-end de réouverture des
commerces ravis de pouvoir faire les
boutiques et commencer les achats de
noël
premièrement pour aider les commerçants
je pense que c'est la première chose qui
me tient à coeur
aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils ont souffert
énormément de la fermeture donc voilà on
attendait d'eux le premier jour pour
vous pour faire nos cadeaux va commencer
au moins à faire nos cadeaux de noël
moi ça ne me gêne pas de sortir avec les
les mesures barrières et les précautions
à prendre
il faut continuer à vivre malgré tout le
mois de décembre s'annonce ce bon selon
cette commerçante les achats en ligne ne
remplace pas le service en boutique
on va faire un carton je pense que les
gens ont vraiment attendu j'ai beaucoup
de clients qui réclamait justement les
magasins et pas le commerce en ligne
mais bonne cliente ont besoin de ce
conseil de pouvoir essayer de pouvoir
toucher on apporte un service
supplémentaire pour ce premier week-end
de réouverture le centre commercial a
accueilli près de 30 de 1600 personnes
soit 21 % de fréquentation en plus sur
le week end par rapport à l'année
dernière